hello folks my name is Sal Dooley I'm a
software engineer here at Google and I'm
joined here by Maisie Maisie is an SRE
on the gke team Mesa can you explain
what an SRE is so SME stands for a site
reliability engineer and the main
difference between me and any other
software engineer is that I have more of
a focus on reliability scalability and
just general efficiency of the running
of the thing that I'm owning which is
deiicate so what does that mean when you
own gke
are you responsible for running it what
do you do for customers sure so the idea
is that we set SLO switch our service
level objectives which are measurements
of how reliable we want the running
service to be and my job is to do any
kind of engineering really that's
required to make sure that we're meeting
those goals
got it so how does this differ from a
traditional kind of DevOps role so I
think that that's a lot of interplay
between DevOps and SOA they're fairly
tightly coupled okay and in terms of
some of the challenges that you see in
your day to day job well what are they
can you talk about that sure so I think
that one of the big challenges for gke
which is a massive hosted kubernetes
system is really just the diversity of
use cases we run a five digit number of
clusters and every user has slightly
different needs and slightly different
configurations so we're constantly
seeing new challenges crop up that's
awesome so how do you actually deal with
them are there practices best practices
do you have any suggestions for
customers or do you take care of most of
the pain for them so we try to take care
of anything that's on the platform level
and anything that is really internal so
that anything that a user can't take
action to fix is super frustrating for
them and we don't want them to have to
deal with that but in general the
philosophy of SOA is to reduce the time
to mitigate a broken system so we may
not have a perfect fix or perfectly
understand the problem but our goal is
always to make the user able to use
their system again fast and then figure
it out after the fact with post-mortems
what happened and make sure that it
doesn't happen again exactly and
wherever possible to build system
to do that and build it into the code
rather than relying on humans to come in
and fix something very cool and so when
we were talking off-camera you were
mentioning some really interesting
design patterns that that sre deals with
could you talk about that sure so one of
the challenges in hosting a massive
deployment of kubernetes clusters which
I talked a little bit about earlier is
that the traditional SME model for a
hyper scalable system is to build a
multi-tenant system and what that means
is that all of your query flow and user
action is flowing through a single
binary or a single replicated set of
binaries now a more traditional monolith
for a single user is what we call a
single tenant system so for example an
Oracle database it has one user and it's
completely specified for that user and
it's been tweaked and perfected for
exactly their use case but it's really
only useful to one person at once the
challenge in hosting these kubernetes
clusters is that every single kubernetes
cluster is in its own way from my point
of view a single tenant system you know
this system belongs to one user this
system belongs to a different customer
they don't have any interaction with
each other and as an operator I can't
really treat them as a monolith so we're
trying to develop some new operations
patterns for how we deal with that and
keep them all running when they're so
different from one another and that's
what we've been calling starting to call
multi single tenant systems got it is
this a pattern that customers could
potentially apply in their own systems
absolutely whenever you have a customer
who is building something that has many
separate users pipeline or shop
deployment or anything along those lines
there are very similar patterns to keep
in mind it definitely helps with
scalability of their solutions for sure
I think one of the key principles that
we're starting to come up with is really
that automation is king and that
monitoring and trying to make sure that
you can have some equivalent monitoring
between each of your single tenant
systems because it doesn't matter
whether you are using your kubernetes
cluster to host a machine learning
pipeline and I'm using mine to host
a YouTube front page both of us have a
control plane that has uptime and it's
meaningful to measure control plane
uptime and I can compare our two
clusters with that that's super
interesting let's take a step back and
talk about a little bit about your
background and how you got into sorry so
I joined Google in 2012 as a new
graduate with a master's in CS degree
and I went straight into the Google Ads
SME team okay sorry not at all I had
offers from three separate teams and one
of them was an SME and I went to some of
my friends at Google I said what's an
SME and they said well they wear leather
jackets and they swear a lot and they're
always really on the go and stressed out
I'm like that sounds great
sign me up oh man and it seems like
you've enjoyed it since yeah what do you
recommend for new grads who are trying
to follow a similar journey what should
they look into and what are the kind of
things that can help them determine
whether to follow this Ari path or a
different path
well one of the things that they might
want to have a look at is the SOE book
we recently came out with the SME
workbook and I actually have a write-up
of one of the big gke
outages in that workbook if people are
curious and another thing is just try
spinning up some systems and try
breaking them don't just try to make
them work try to break them and figure
out how they break and if that's
interesting to you then this might be an
area to pursue yeah I think there might
be a lot of folks out there that are
interested in that so thank you for that
let's switch gears a little bit and talk
about coupon this is your first coupon
order your impressions it's huge
yes it is it's really really big I was a
little surprised about the gender
diversity here my essary team is about
half women which is a little bit unusual
but I was not expecting it to be quite
as masculine what can we do to improve
that I mean I think that it's really a
question of looking at how the community
treats various people I know that in the
past I've had some challenges with a
very feminine name in open-source
getting code reviews it feels like you
get a bit more pushback but also just
one of the things that
I did notice that coupe con is working
on is having technical women on stage
right all of the keynotes have had a
huge number of really impressive women
like Janet and Liz and that's something
I super appreciate not as awesome and
finally let's wrap up with what are you
looking forward to most to keep on is
there a talk or whatever honestly I am
looking forward to talking to other
people who are using kubernetes in ways
that we are not right I feel like that's
what I get the most out of is one-to-one
conversations figuring out where
people's pain points are how they're
different from mine because I have a bit
of a weird perspective on kubernetes I
don't use coupon a tease I run
kubernetes right so it's a bit of it and
if we can figure out how customers are
using it in ways that we don't expect we
can make it more robust and reliable
over time that's the idea that is the
role of SRE thank you very much me thank
you pleasure talking to you
[Music]